new goldlinks is about uh DC's past
present and future in the wake of
Flashpoint Beyond six what we learn is
that rip Hunter
pulled 13 characters out of History
essentially out of the golden age for
some reason we don't know yet and those
13 heroes are being put back into
history so the new golden age is a
storyline that takes place from the
1940s all the way to the 31st century
and the one shot will kick that
storyline off that storyline then goes
off into Star Girl the Lost Children And
Justice side of America but it's really
only the beginning of it but there are a
lot of great scenes throughout that just
take a look at these characters as
humans and what they're dealing with
because the weight of being a part of
this Legacy of the JSA it's different
than being just a superhero because
there is a history to it all there's
people that came before you start over
the lost children really tackles the
whatever happened to the arrow Sidekicks
when Courtney and red arrow are on the
trail of this missing Golden Age
sidekick they uncover a mystery that
will reveal a previous the Unseen almost
Legion of Sidekicks from the Golden Age
and we'll find out what this villain the
child minder is doing with them and who
are they working for and working with
Todd knock from Young Justice Fame he's
Illustrated the series but detail in
this artwork is
unbelievable I've never seen his work
look so good it's inspired a bit by
George Perez because of the detail the
number of characters Justice side of
America is about a society of
superheroes from the beginnings of the
JSA in the 1940s all the way to their
future this is every character that's
ever been connected to JSA this is a
story that wheeze between everyone and
takes on what the legacy of the JSA
really means because really there's a
force here that's trying to not just
tackle the team now but destroy it
through all eras and then with Mikhail
Jan and he's been doing stunning work in
Flashpoint Beyond and the same with the
JSA but there's something so beautiful
and rendered about his artwork and the
characters have so much personality when
he draws them you're just drawn right
into them
[Music]
thank you
[Music]